Britten's patchwork landscape has been
sculpted by human activity forests have
been cleared and peatlands drained to
make way for crops and livestock and
it's the same the world over the United
Nations scientist warned in a new report
that almost a quarter of greenhouse gas
is now originated from our use and abuse
of land and is no longer sustainable
according to the intergovernmental panel
on climate change 72% of the planets
ice-free surface is now used to feed
clothe and support the growing human
population the food sector is
responsible for 75% of all deforestation
and farmers now use twice as much water
and nine times as much artificial
fertilizer as they did in the 1960s
competition but agricultural land will
only get worse around the world farmers
are increasingly growing crops for
energy biofuels for cars and aircraft
but the report warns that's no dream fix
for climate change in poorer countries
in particular they compete with food
crops and that can increase the risk of
hunger we will need to see ourselves as
carbon farmers according to the report
agroforestry is one solution to climate
change
Helen browning has planted fruit and nut
trees on her pasture in time they'll
provide shelter for her cows and suck
carbon out of the air to store
underground overall you get a lot more
yield per acre if you have both tree
crops and grass or arable crops in the
same block of land the tree roots go
deep into the soil and will bring up
nutrients minerals and things that would
otherwise perhaps just be leached away
or just remain there and return those to
the soil through leaf fall
but soil is being eroded faster than its
formed even modest rainfall simulated in
this laboratory washes away bare earth
along with the carbon and vital
nutrients it contains so I think people
take soil for granted you know they
refer to it as mud or dirt or you know
very negative connotations yet it is so
fundamental to society and as again the
goods and services that we get from soil
these Somerset marshes were once
farmland now restored they lock up
carbon in the ground if we eat less meat
waste less food and free up the land
nature is part of the solution to the
climate crisis Thomas More Sky News